we were we were very very lucky being in
the first round of like combinator
because that alone generated a lot of
interest a lot of readers of Paul Graham
were just excited to see what was gonna
come up and we were the first ones to
launch and and with that we got a fair
amount of attention just being the first
YC startup but most importantly we got a
lot of attention from Paul's readers he
would write about us in his blog he
would mention us during talks and and he
would say very nice things that were
that were totally true he he really did
spend a lot of time on Reddit back then
and so having that kind of endorsement
and having Paul Graham's readership
coming to your site and contributing to
it and building the foundation of the
community was a just really invaluable
way to start reddit otherwise you know
you're really just sort of stuck on
whoever you can browbeat into using your
site and we we begged plenty of our
friends and family to use it if you did
Morgan Connor and you both Rock and they
were regular users I had to give them
their shout out but for the most part a
lot of those early users were actually
Steven me with aliases
we had silly usernames that we just
generated in order to make it look like
there was a diversity of users on the
site
I don't feel too bad about this because
we didn't have commenting back then so
it wasn't like I was responding to my
own comment saying brilliant comment
Alexis but we we knew that for a new
user for let's say one of these Paul
Graham readers who saw the reddit shot
in his essay for them to come to Reddit
and not find anything new and
interesting for them to find a list full
of links all submitted by spez or all
submitted by nothing was gonna be a
fairly disheartening experience and so
we needed to use a little bit of I hate
to say it but I mean deception frankly
to show that there was more activity on
the site than there actually was
fortunately though about a month or so
into Reddit we both had this moment
where we spent the whole day you know
using Reddit just like anyone else we
could vote on stories and that was it we
didn't submit anything and at the end of
that day we looked at each other and
realized holy this might actually
work maybe we haven't been wasting our
time the site is actually alive and that
was a really really crucial moment for
us it was before we took any angel
funding you know we were still in fact
for the entire duration of our setup we
were pretty much living on pizza but we
were still a very nascent stage in
reddit and that was the first bit of
validation we had gotten and it felt
great and it kind of just kept growing
from there
okay there was there was this whole
other area of personal stuff going on
that I won't even touch on the business
the startup side of things were
harrowing and I mean I don't want to
over dramatize this I know there's a
popular Facebook movie coming out that
overdramatize this startup life so I
don't need to add to that but Steve
literally did sleep with his laptop for
a number of months mostly because the
site was still written and lists back
but back then and it was less than ideal
at least in certain circumstances and so
there was no shortage of stuff that was
going wrong in any given moment not just
on the technical side I mean things just
break all the time and things just
happen and startup life is adapting to
it dealing with it but on the on the the
sort of non-technical side of things
every opportunity remember this is pre
Twitter so I've just dated myself but
every opportunity to see someone talking
about reddit whether it was on a blog I
still remember the first blog that I
ever wrote about us I think was called
the changing way with some dudes
WordPress blog and I still remember the
look of it because he had a photo of
those really distinctive orange flags
that they put up all over Central Park a
few years back anyway he was the first
person ever write about reddit and both
Steve and I commented on that site and
said thank you thank you thank you you
know please keep the feedback coming and
that was that was great it was like for
once someone other than us and our moms
cared about our website
well yes and no the the weird thing
about reddit is that for a community its
size now I'm no longer at reddit but the
public traffic numbers that they put out
are I think with the cited about 8
million unique visitors a month or every
30 days which is a fairly big site
what's a real mine job is I think most
of our users don't realize that or they
think the site feels a lot smaller
because it is for a site that big I
would I would be willing to put them up
against any other community on the
internet for being one of the most
tight-knit or most strongest communities
especially for one of that scale and so
the site has never really it's certainly
grown and it's matured and it feels very
different than it did when we started at
five years ago but in other ways it
still feels small and and from our side
of things you know where is sort of the
janitors of Reddit you know we keep the
site running we keep everyone having a
good time we keep the bathrooms clean
for the most part and and and try to
make the site an enjoyable experience
but we've always stayed a remarkably
small team even now I guess if you
include contractors there's six or seven
people working on Reddit but when we got
acquired there were basically three and
then in the years since you know we've
added three more developer hires if it
was full-time and a community manager
but the site is still remarkably small
and and the ratio of developers to users
I think is one of the best Craigslist
probably still beats it but is the one
of the best on the web so it still feels
very small we never developed enough of
a corporate hierarchy for it to feel
like a real company it it's always been
a group of us working in a often stuffy
but once we got the qanun asked slightly
nice like nicer and larger and prettier
office but all working together and
obviously I'm thankful we got out of
that apartment in Somerville where there
were four of us crammed on a sloped
sloped floor so that we had to actually
tape the wheels of a rolling computer
chair so we wouldn't be sliding into
each other but it's come a long way and
yet still the site feels very small and
I'm still friends with everyone who's
there and it's then it's still an
incredible thought to see just how much
it has grown
back in the day I would say they
reflected I see not okay they were
similar to like geeks like me and Steve
I mean frankly like I said we were
submitting most of the content early on
and you know we can we are readers of
Paul Graham and so I can open that more
broadly and be a little bit less
narcissistic and say you know it was
those early reader early users of Reddit
were like Paul Graham fans so people
interested in technology people
interested the early adopters and in
trying out new things and also people
who were just interested in having a
fairly broad worldview and understanding
and knowing what was going on and then
being on top of that and being the taste
maker for all their friends since I feel
like it's expanded a bit but read it
still remains fairly Keke's not the
right word but they the sort of people
who use reddit I think are also the sort
of people who others go to for their
recommendations whether it's what movie
they should see or what computer they
should buy or what distro Linux they
should be installing it's it has always
remained I feel there's something about
the site that draws the kind of person
who is even if they're not submitting
majority the users just visit the site
to find out what's new interesting but
it draws the kind of person who is
genuinely curious about being in the
know and and and wants to if not share
it you know whether it's through email
or I am however they want to do on their
Facebook wall to at least be a part of
some experience that is happening that
is a little bit bigger than you know
what's going on in each of our own
little individual worlds I do wish the
site had a better ratio of men to women
it's still a fairly male and this is
based on survey data but it's still a
fairly fairly male heavy site I'm always
thrilled when ever I meet female our
editors and I I mean I I've seen very
anecdotally from meetups since since we
started and started doing basically
inviting redditors out for free drinks
that the ratio is actually gotten much
much better um and that's that's always
a nice thing but but for the most part
it's still yeah a fairly geeky audience
I guess there's 8 million geeks who want
to visit the site every month which is
encouraging we need to breed more people
we don't we don't know ethnic breakdown
via the demographic data that I have is
from campaigns that we ran mostly for
the benefit of advertisers but we also
I'm pretty sure we shared these publicly
where there's no reason why I wouldn't
if and and so we had a significant
sample size so I feel pretty good about
this sort of data most redditors are at
least college-educated a number of them
have post or graduate to rather than
graduate degrees a number of them are in
the IT tech world I guess that's the
bubble they chose to fill in on the form
trying of other interesting stuff fairly
us-based but actually I believe it's
60/40 60% u.s. 40% abroad which is
exciting
mostly mostly in english-speaking
countries UK Canada Australia but but
seeing 40% interpretate representation
is great because I I
I don't know I'm my most when I've got
my soap box out and what I'm thinking I
don't know most idealistic Lee about
reddit I like to think that it could be
a truly global community obviously there
are lots of people who just don't have
access to the Internet in a way that is
much more prevalent in the developed
world but just having a more global
perspective I think is exciting and in
benefits the whole community